Speaker 1: There is evidence to criminally
charge the failed former president Donald Trump,
says Adam Schiff, member of the January 6th
committee. We have video of Adam Schiff explaining
I've seen the evidence. There is evidence that
Donald Trump committed criminal offenses in his
effort to overturn the 2020 election. Now,
Adam Schiff has previously said things like,
we have the evidence that will put Dan Junior
in prison or at least get him charged. And it
appears as though he was wrong about
that. So Adam Schiff is no panacea,
but we are within hours right now of the January
six committee making criminal referrals. We don't
yet know who's going to be on that list. And
you have Adam Schiff saying the following.
Let's take a listen and then discuss what we'll
discuss. Well, what could be those charges?
Speaker 2: I think that the evidence is there
that Donald Trump committed criminal offenses
in connection with his efforts to overturn the
election and viewing it. As a former prosecutor,
I think there's sufficient evidence to charge
the president. Why? I don't know. Well,
I don't know what the Justice Department has. I
do know what's in the public record. The evidence
seems pretty plain to me. But I would want
to see the full body of evidence if I were
in the prosecutor's shoes to make a decision.
But, you know, this is someone who in multiple
ways tried to pressure state officials to find
votes that didn't exist. This is someone who
tried to interfere with a joint session, even
inciting a mob to attack the Capitol. True.
If that's not criminal, then. Not all it is.
Speaker 1: So let's take this seriously and
think it through. Let's not speak in general terms
about this. According to the investigation, by the
January six committee, there is evidence that
Trump committed crimes. That's what Adam Schiff
is telling us. And we've heard it from others.
The committee did find that Trump made false
statements about the results of the 2020 election
in so far as he claimed that he won even though he
lost. And then he used those false statements to
encourage his followers to challenge the results.
In so doing, he encouraged the violent attack
on the US Capitol on January six, 2021,
which about a million of us on our stream watched
live on that day. The evidence against Trump
includes his own words, which the committee has
looked at extensively. The actions of those who
participated in the attacks and their claims that
they were there because Trump told them to go.
Trump made repeated claims that the election was
stolen from him. He made false claims that it was
stolen in particular ways none of which were found
to be have any merit. He urged his supporters to,
quote, never give up, to never concede, to
fight like hell, to march to the Capitol,
to show support for him. In addition to Trump's
public words, we have evidence of the planning and
the coordination and the behind the scenes of this
plan that was drafted up for Trump, for Mike Pence
to again, at this point, we don't even really
understand what he was supposed to do, quote,
send it back to the states or recognize alternate
electors, all the things that he couldn't do.
But there was planning, there was legal work that
went into that. And we have other individuals that
were involved who were caught on video discussing
the plan, discussing how to disrupt the election
results. And some were even seeing wearing
tactical gear and some of them even had weapons.
So this was all a major plan. If Donald Trump
were to be charged in connection with the attack
from what happened on January 6th, the possible
consequences could include fines, imprisonment
or both. And we'll talk about the prison piece a
little later. Glenn Kershner had an interesting
comment about that's all hypothetical,
but what would the specific charges be?
Trump could face potentially incitement to riot
conspiracy, obstruction of justice among other
crimes. Each carries its own potential
penalties, and the penalties depend on
the severity of the offense and other factors,
including what he would ultimately be convicted
of in this completely hypothetical scenario we're
talking about now, of course. Just because you're
charged doesn't mean you're going to be found
guilty. In the interview with Adam Schiff. Jake
TAPPER asks a good question, which is, okay,
you might have the evidence for an indictment,
but you have the evidence for a conviction. Those
are two dramatically different questions. And at
the end of the the entire thing is a question
I've asked before. Can you find a jury in the
United States that will fairly adjudicate
Donald Trump? And what I mean by that is,
is there really anyone in the U.S. who would
say, I am open minded enough about Trump
that whatever preconceived notions I have about
him and what he did, I will rule based only on
the evidence presented in this trial. I don't know
that I could do that. I don't know that I could do
that because it would be very difficult for me to
completely put aside everything that over the last
five years and in the couple of years since the
riots in the year plus since the riot, almost two
years since the riots, I have learned about Donald
Trump. So so there is a real question, can Trump
get an actual fair jury trial in the U.S.? That'll
be a conversation we have a little bit later.